despite a shorter run the season was
full of Easter eggs and in this video
I'm bringing in top three things you
completely missed number three the arrow
head shaped Mountain in the very
beginning of the season seven Center
looked into the flames and saw a vision
the fountain saw a mountain shaped like
an arrow a castle on the wall and the
whites marching towards it which
resulted that the Brotherhood had to
Eastwatch and eventually to become part
of Jon Snow's mission to capture white
the already mentioned mountain where the
hounds vision led the search party was
previously also seen in Burns vision
about the creation of the first white
Walker little seem to be pretty much the
same but it remains unclear if it's
supposed to be the same mountain within
the fictional narrative or if the show
was just reusing a filming location
number two desecrated Darville
statuettes early in season 7 there's a
scene with Jon Snow is coming out of the
crypts where he had encountered
Littlefinger eagle-eyed fans would have
noticed that the very stone direwolf
engraving sense that shreds had been
smashed or defaced prior to Jon Snow's
returned by the Bolton's off-screen and
the Bolton's took over Winterfell the
goal was to destroy everything related
to the Starks and exert their own
dominance they wanted people of the
north to fear the name Bolton and forget
the word stark since the Starks took
over the control they apparently set
about restoring those as well
number one the track wearing pieces of
Lannister armor in the season 7 finale
if examined closely to the track Eko
accompanied the party to the dragon pit
can be seen varying glennister codes as
well as bits and pieces of Lannister
armor from their victory of the
Blackwater rush one soldier is seen with
the Lannister commanders paul-jean
others are seen with arm braces and
summit decorative lion brooches as it
had been shown that the track eluded
corpses in the aftermath of the Battle
of the gold road and are now proudly
displaying the spoils of war this also
indicates a steady drop in temperature
even in the south and the Dothraki
onions to this colder climates naturally
lauded warmer clothing from their slain
enemies their head guides those would be
top three things you most probably
missed in season 7 in the days and
months to come you can expect more
predictions theories and spoilers
regarding the final season so make sure
you stay tuned